so last week Mia Khalifa the former porn
star came out and said that she only
made 12 grand from her very shortly
lived adult film career and a lot of
porn anymore
no she said tell me I'll make him I'm
watching reruns
she says that for she made about a dozen
videos within the span of a month or two
more than that Playgirl she only made a
dozen but what ends up happening is that
people are then taking the videos and
reposting them on other accounts so it
seems like she's still in active yeah I
thought she was but a lot of people
she's done worked in every month well
she could do it now she should go into
another one for a shitload of money and
I just uploaded on her own page well she
has a great career outside of porn now
and what uh you know she had a sports
show on I believe it was either
barstools or complex something like that
she had she's doing pretty well for
herself now she's hot
juicy shaker's dude yeah I wanna see
baby want a restaurant she's actually
well sure boy she's actually well known
for the video she did with a hijab she
did like a Muslim related foreign video
that gone girl those breasts real real
big yeah who's that guy
legend were England
nope she's from here the United States
he's just from Florida sexy look at it
right there you never seen her work
right no she was suck the skin off a
date really
she's never it to horn huh I don't watch
porn
no IMF they don't watch porn I I've seen
all her work is I'm gonna watch porn now
I watch it works like it's a Quinton
Tarantino really oh yeah they're the
headman's all surprised I haven't
watched point and so [ __ ] long well
you cuz you're older I know this year's
birthday I just really haven't watched
porn I don't know how long I told you
one time I was nice for my dad I was
watching porn
my father was going what is all this
porn like you know Oscar I was like I
don't I was watching but I it was just
that was a one-time thing
dude they told her I doubt that play
they tell her that you tell me those
amazing pornos she did like there's like
you can watch somewhere three black as I
team up on her more than that sometimes
I love you don't get 12 grand
she made 12 videos each video was about
a thousand for a flat rate but this was
before she started popping off this is
before she became popular and so the big
debate with this is should porn
companies give her residuals for the
amount of work she's doing cuz she's
still to this day such a big name and
porn even though she's been out of it
for years I had no idea she was out
she's big in like Asia I'm sure and
she's been here Brian
younger she's huge here yeah she's
fantastic
pretty girl Wow I don't know she's out
she's uh and now she has a career yes
doing other stuff what kind of I think I
don't know how many do way how many
followers have some crazy in 16 I'm so
great oh Jesus Christ she's huge she's
making a fortune then this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]